painting this galaxy on my nails I think
is probably harder than actually flying
and dabbing face I'm just gonna go for
it I'm just gonna put the polish on the
sponge they didn't really neatly I don't
see that happening
it's just blobs it'll get there it's
actually really pretty he never give up
on yourself I'm gonna start Pinterest
thing I really think that this pink is
going to like make this entire thing pop
oh man that was so disappointing every
time I put on a layer it covered up the
last layer how am I gonna do my right
hand I think they were prettier without
it I shouldn't have done it
look how beautiful it looks without the
stars and look how damn it looks this
cars I have absolutely no confidence and
myself being able to do this it's gonna
be bad now I think I put the different
colors of the ombre on the sponge I have
my stripes which oh my god this looks oh
oh never been good at pinches
[Laughter]
it's also not what I was going for I'm
an art major so I feel like I should be
able to do this it already doesn't look
like the picture here we go
whoa it's not quite like the pictures
but some good stuff was happening going
in for nail number two oh no something
went wrong
this isn't good guys I am going to have
to clean up a whole lot I have a lot of
respect for the people on Pinterest who
can do this because I can't and I'm an
art major I don't think it's gonna be
easy
really time-consuming but ultimately
worth it my fear is like I'll put the
tape on I'm gonna rip it off and then I
have no nail polish ever putting on the
tape it's actually way crazier than I
thought I'm gonna have to like measure
this it's like surgery it's like who has
time for this the other hand is gonna be
completely disaster I can already tell
you right now oh it's totally skipped a
finger for totally free out of my finger
you know what I probably would have been
better at freestyling this tape is so
hard oh my god enough to cut with my
left hand how long has it been
I can't remember a time before this okay
not too bad okay this hand is done this
is pretty cool there's something there I
would say you need a good three hours
this is that thing you do now and like
then your nails are wet and you like you
don't want to like touch anything
I grab anything out right yep I already
[ __ ] this one up I know how they put
so many dots on one nail on that nail is
shorter than mine I will say this very
relaxing yeah I want to try to get like
a thin line and look like those painting
people think our vaginas but if you if
we did a video like this of like doing
your nails while you're drunk it would
still look exactly like this remember
when I said this was relaxing now I'm
finding it tedious the green helps a lot
to like really feel like this is a
flower I would do this again I might
just do like an accent nail on each hand
because I think this is also kind of a
lot
I think no one looks good when they've
made their own nails like we all look
like we just learned so we had opposable
thumbs or something and like just
burying enough the first time